we also had Hezbollah which is the
Lebanese terrorist group they called for
a uh a an unprecedented day of anger
tomorrow um globally for jihadis
everywhere uh in response to Biden's
visit to Israel yeah they're saying
they're saying War they're saying War
well Hezbollah is saying war and you
also have Hezbollah and Hamas are are
backing each other even though one is
Shia and one is Sunni but they hate the
Jews in America more than they hate each
other mhm so the the big concern is uh
uh right now we have this reporting from
ABC News Biden has departed for Israel
and canceled the the Jordan Summit I
believe I don't know exactly why let's
let's actually just uh just pull this up
and see what their the the latest
development uh development is uh they
say Israel at least 400 people have died
3,400 have been injured Israeli forces
launched air strikes this we know
conditions are are getting worse